[Applause]
good morning Minnie good morning
what is this okay so where's the flavors
meaning so American that he wants candy
for breakfast well I would the taste
like ass
really I thought you know I'll try one
do you rent one rent one is good
no it's like bread one is good oh sure
yeah it comes late yeah it's our ass
hello Sam
yeah we like some sour we're going to
Disneyland every one so excited why
aren't you smiling Anthony aren't you
happy we're literally like twelve people
all going to do some lame this has gotta
be outside I'm so excited we're going on
this one are you ready
I spray water on me
I love jerking off god damn it you cut
up on me
okay I never went on this one it's
really terrifying really am I gonna cry
good
[Applause]
I wonder how can I want to jump up
really high up that was awesome I really
like that what are we doing now guys
already screaming yes I'm gonna try to
vlog well are you gonna try to we're
gonna try not to scream I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now it's perfect
they're good my boyfriend is buying me
again you're welcome darling so this is
an unboxing is a brand new else unboxing
this is done by yeah yeah are you happy
with your accomplice she's gonna go with
me everywhere her hair's of the place
[Music]
all right we're moving on to the next
park so excited we're gonna do Splash
Mountain no one cares that mountain yes
yeah hey guys
so that's what I wanted
[Applause]
that is amazing
okay it's only our throw in the elevator
okay please camera the Nightmare Before
Christmas version
[Music]
oh my god
Oh
[Music]
how excited are you for Space Mountain
space-bound beach already are we
[Music]
[Applause]
see me I'm so scared
enjoy I'm so scared
Jesus Christ okay all right we're gonna
so many right okay
whoever wins wins something okay for
nine thousand thirty nine thousand I win
you get to buy me Elsa what happened
okay we're going out ripping it the bun
day we have to go this way we're gonna
have dinner look at what happened we are
going to check out the lunar eclipse and
go to the other side and check out Tara
Tara wait look who's excited to go back
to Disneyland yes it's like
that's my bedtime okay there it is
Anthony wow that's so cool it is cool
you know that's really cool Anthony yes
the lunar eclipse more like lamer
Eclipse up top that looks pretty cool
actually I never seen one before I get a
good shot
we're going crazy
[Applause]
okay another ride apparently I don't
know we go right this is the wet one yes
girls versus boys okay here we go
many it's been good knowing you it's
been fun this is the end
Wow drop drop it's brainy big man I
don't know if I can handle it
right here with behind me and shot out
of my cross this is so pretty
oh my god it's gonna be the longest vlog
ever I can't believe how much I film
today
let's go are you ready to race
[Music]
[Applause]
you [ __ ] want
[Music]
we are in a car we have so much energy
can you tell no no oh my god oh I'm so
tired
Venice Beach with all the weirdos I
guess I'm one of them because I'm
vlogging
this tree is so done with life I would
be too if I was a tree